there are many truly terrifying legends
that originate from Native American
folklore one that stands out for many is
the Wendigo maybe because deep down it
reflects our very own human nature but
the religions out there that we know
next to nothing about because they are
deemed so horrid so evil that even
talking about them or mentioning them in
passing is a bad omen today's video will
be on an ad lu-shi
the Navajo skinwalker now skinwalkers or
a topic I've wanted to cover for a while
but the taboo around the subject does
mean there isn't a wealth of information
out there so I guess we start with the
obvious what exactly is a skinwalker and
first grant skinwalkers are essentially
shapeshifters but shapeshifter in itself
is a very loose term you can transform
into an animal an object or another
human it literally just means you can
alter your shape or form the
transformation of skinwalkers for the
most part is limited to just animals the
biggest hint we get is from its native
name nat Liu Shi in the Navajo language
this roughly translates to mean he or
she who goes on all fours but that
doesn't necessarily limit the
transformation to four-legged animals
the Navajo saw skinwalkers as powerful
witches or corrupt medicine men who had
attained the highest level of priesthood
but instead they choose to use these
supernatural abilities to inflict harm
and suffering on others the fear of
repercussion coupled with a distrust of
outsiders are two fairly compelling
reasons why skinwalkers aren't openly
talked about there is also the belief
that skinwalkers only share their
practices with their own kind which only
adds to the mystery surrounding them
this also means it's unlikely that the
Navajo know who among them is actually a
skinwalker as they transform under the
cover of night what type of animal they
transform into does seem to vary the
most common being a coyote which is
often seen as a trickster they can also
take the form of other animals such as
foxes wolves owls Eagles and crows the
form they take depends on what they
require as each animal has a different
set of unique abilities if they planned
on attacking someone then a wolf would
be a
choice whereas transforming into some
kind of bird offers the ability of
flight and even something like a crow
being an omen of death could act as a
warning or a threat the skinwalker wears
the skin of the animal they transform
into hence the name but we're in the
skin of most animals were seen as taboo
by many tribes and the Navajo only wore
sheepskin and buckskin when it came to
ceremonial purposes so unless the
skinwalkers only wore these skins during
the night it kind of defeats the whole
you never know who the skinwalker among
you is because it's obviously the person
wearing the animal skin what it actually
takes to become a skinwalker no one
really knows for sure but as which is a
medicine men it's believed that a ritual
must be performed and given their nature
it's likely to have been the dark and
nefarious kind there is also the belief
that to become a skinwalker you must
first take the life of someone close to
you a friend or family member so if some
do in fact demon worthy of taking the
life of another then surely what you
receive in return must be impressive
will along with being able to turn into
animals
skinwalkers can mimic the sound or voice
of any animal or human with the
transformation comes enhanced stamina
strength and speed catching a skinwalker
and animal form is thought to be nigh on
impossible some skinwalkers were even
capable of reading the human mind and if
one was to stare into the eyes of a
skinwalker for long enough they can
enter your mind and take control of your
body
there isn't much said about how one
kills a skinwalker but similar to
stories of werewolves some believe
that's a nay skinwalkers full name out
loud or result in them having to atone
for their crimes and even dying in some
cases it's difficult to say for sure
what a skinwalkers motives are they may
be seen as evil but they are still human
unlike some humans they are driven by
their own selfish and malicious nature
as you may expect over the years there
have been hundreds of stories of people
claiming to have seen or encountered
skinwalkers but none of these have been
proven if a video detailing some of
these accounts and stories is something
you'd like to see then let me know in
the comments below if you have enjoyed
this video then please don't forget to
leave a thumbs up as it really does go a
long way as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained
you